[Música]
[Aplausos]
quienes nos hemos encontrado una
situación así donde tenemos más de cinco
puertas y ciertas situaciones que
tenemos que encontrarnos donde hay
muchas posibilidades bueno les quiero
contar algo a mis 17 años mi vida ha
cambiado mi decisión familiar
no está en mis manos mis padres se
divorcian y mi padre de dos años después
nos abandona
eso hace que muchos cambios comiencen en
mí como sea
pero positivamente comenzó a ser una
persona soñadora visionaria emprendedora
luchadora determinada
y gracias a dios
con mucha gente alrededor mío que me da
esa fuerza para poder dar más adelante y
por ese poder decir determinadamente que
puede dar más lejos situaciones
inesperadas con fe y con experiencias
fracasos inspiración y huelva un
emprendedor a mi mitad sólo 19 años
con muchas responsabilidades con mucha
fuerza con mucha energía pero sobre todo
con mucha sabiduría y mucha bendición
y no sólo esto sino que lo que sucede es
que yo no sé nada mi padre los últimos
15 años sucede que nos pagaran los
abandonas al país no sabiendo dónde
estaba
pero eso hace entre mis decisiones de
vida en algún momento buscar ese perdón
encontrar ese momento de verdad regresar
a mi ser y decir necesito hacer un
perdón
entro en una búsqueda de alma espíritu
de cuerpo algo que va más allá de mí
donde digo tengo que hacerlo porque sin
esto no voy a llegar más lejos esas
luchas constantes donde uno llega y no
voltea a ver y dice qué lindo donde nos
ha llevado a la vida
pero si no perdonamos vamos a hacer esa
honrada a honrar al padre a nuestra
madre como todas las cosas dije bueno
tengo que hacerlo es hace tres años
empiezo a indagar sobre mi pierna mente
y hace dos semanas hago el encuentro y
este encuentro ha sido la transición más
grande que logrado hacer
porque no va a tener palabras de lo que
oí como alma vaya a ser el día de mañana
y entonces darme cuenta entre todas los
momentos que yo me siento y darme cuenta
que hay muchas cosas que yo no sabía que
era un ser que no somos perfectos que
realmente podemos cambiar y que tenemos
nuestras razones y que también somos
libres como seres de tomar nuestras
decisiones
entonces uno de mis estadios al juntarme
con el rut número seis final
es definitivamente no puedo tomar una
decisión sin tener toda la información
toda esa data y de información
incompleta
eso hace mi búsqueda hace tres años y
decir más allá de la información cómo
está el mundo hoy por hoy hacer una
retrospección y el siglo bueno somos
hace un año 27.6 millones de personas en
2025 108.1 millones de personas el 2050
9 vehículos de personas la curva va para
arriba el 43% de las personas estamos
conectadas todo el tiempo entre
instagram facebook y todo eso está
generando datos todo el tiempo 50
millones de dispositivos van a estar
conectados en tan solo un par de años y
el 2025 y lo más increíble que encontré
fue una de las formaciones del fuego fue
un libro increíble el 90% mundial ha
sido creada en los últimos dos años
tan solo hace 30 años 5.000 computadores
que lo que procesar lo procesa ahora un
celular se puede imaginar eso un
gigabyte costaba 10 mil dólares de
almacenamiento hoy cuesta una fracción
centavos de dólar hoy la tecnología está
de nuestro lado y eso hace todo el
tiempo poder eficientizar nuestras vidas
todo el tiempo lo estamos utilizando
para muchas razones
todo esto está conectado con un tema de
inteligencia artificial
y qué va a pasar plataformas increíbles
como una persona un asistente personal
inteligente comienza a parecer en los
últimos dos años lo que es álex así y
cortan a vehículos autónomos lo que es
guay mont es la ubr que utilizamos
bastantes cuando vayamos ahora la
empresa más grande sin tener ningún taxi
amazon ayudaba vídeo más grande del
mundo con solo todo el día generando
información no se ha pasado que cada vez
está mucho más segmentado nuestros
gustos cada vez nos volvemos una persona
con información detrás y todo el tiempo
estamos generando toda esta información
entonces todo esto es disruptivo en
todas las industrias
por ende
vemos que todo esto comienza al ser un
desarrollo generado por información
empresas
servicios gobiernos organizaciones todas
conectadas haciendo colaboración y eso
para mí fue como bueno qué está
sucediendo en el mundo que voy a hacer
para poder entenderlo más y ahí es una
empieza ese nuevo viaje al poder irme al
tema de la vanguardia e ir decir bueno
es ese conocimiento que está viendo más
atrás de nosotros más arriba que no se
ve interconectado que no vemos físico
para qué está sucediendo
me doy cuenta que con esa información
extracción de data la interpretación de
la a es igual a decisiones asertivas en
nuestras vidas y qué vamos a hacer ahora
como vamos a informar con las
internacionalmente al buscar todo esto
encuentro en mi búsqueda de esta nueva
inteligencia artificial
encuentro algo increíble y veo que todo
esto que estoy conectado nos va a llevar
más allá
por ende quiero llevarlos a un viaje
internamente de lo que hace nuestra esta
acción porque lo que logramos hacer y
logró identificar y logró visualizar es
el futuro que nos viene a través de
millones de documentos que todo el
tiempo se está generando a través de
millones de data que estamos generando
información cómo hacer disruptiva toda
esta información
prenden nuestro sistema lo que hace es
importar primero imágenes arbitrarias de
cualquier tipo
sin importar qué
este proyecto
imagen lo que hace es visualizar los que
tenemos diferentes tipos
de escrituras tenemos a mano tenemos a
máquina de escribir dos tipos de
máquinas de escribir y vamos viendo cómo
el mismo algoritmo artificial intenta
oficial comienza a cambiar y hacer un
contraste entre ellos
la normalización de la plantilla lo hace
porque sabemos que cuando escanea estos
estos documentos que son millones de
millones de documentos sabemos que no
van a estar completamente bien entonces
lo que logra hacerlo es extraer esta
plantilla de cierta manera
agrupar las imágenes lo hace solo
entendiendo la información que contiene
y el contenido de cada uno de estos
documentos
y lo que sucede también el sistema
comienza
hacer una división en capaz semánticas
que es eso se encuentra diferentes tipos
de ley outs para poder haciendo una
disrupción entre lo que es la
información de tipo a escrita a mano y
por qué está mano en ese y toda la parte
de máquina de escribir y comienza a
calar toda la información que contiene
ese documento donde se usaba o sea ere y
henry reconoce este sistema reconoce
inclusive determina si es un hombre o
una mujer que escribió este documento
por los trazos que tiene el documento en
sí
es increíble porque lo que hace es
extraerlo y hacer rico texto para
poderlo hacer llevarlo a una base de
datos
esto es lo último que existe y es
increíble porque millones de documentos
pueden estar
siendo extraídos y siendo entendidos
el sistema entiende lo más increíble es
que entiende que esto es una fecha que
tiene una persona que tiene una
localización porque está conectado y
porque tiene todo esto es una ficha
médica
por ende cualquier documento que ustedes
meten al sistema lo puede interpretar
entonces que vemos en este momento que
la transcripción manual de inteligencia
artificial sobre 25 veces más rápido y
cuatro veces más accesible
es increíble porque definitivamente algo
así no aves no existía
y el tener toda esta parte con una
visión de largo plazo donde entendemos
que empresas más competitivas indios más
competitivos países más desarrollados
haremos mucho bases masas más sólidas
para guatemala y no solo para guatemala
sino para latinoamérica para el mundo
donde el generaremos transparencia donde
las informaciones ya no existirá y con
cada información que tengamos podremos
tener decisiones mucho más asertivas sin
ningún sesgo ideológico sino simplemente
la información con mues
perdón
por el tema lo único que les quiero
dejar es que unas cosas que me ha
llevado a este camino ha sido de verdad
liderar con propósito ha sido que las
cosas han sido verdad crearlas
y de verdad las formas ha sido por
decisiones propias para llegar a estos
dos descubrimientos de algoritmo de
inteligencia artificial de situaciones
de tecnología donde la disrupción va a
llevar más allá
y con esto es muchas gracias
[Música]